if you've ever used a card to pay for
something you're definitely familiar
with the names american express visa and
mastercard these three have dominated
the card processing industry for decades
but most people don't know the
difference between them and frankly
there is very little difference between
them from the consumer side if you're
not keen on maximizing credit card
points and rewards however from the
business side american express is
radically different from the other two
american express is not the most common
card by any means
in fact visa and mastercard destroy amex
in terms of issued cards
for example visa has 343 million credit
cards in circulation within the us and
798 million credit cards in circulation
outside the us
similarly mastercard has 249 million
credit cards in the us and 725 million
credit cards outside the u.s this means
that visa has a total of a 1.14 billion
credit card in circulation and a
mastercard has 974 million cards
meanwhile mx only has 53.8 million
credit cards in the us and 58.2 million
credit cards outside the us or just 112
million cards in total this means that
visa and mastercard have issued 20 times
as many cards as amex at first this
looks really bad for amex until you take
a look at their revenue numbers in the
last 12 month period visa pulled in 24.1
billion dollars in revenue and
mastercard pulled in 17.8 billion
revenue together this adds up to 41.9
billion dollars
meanwhile amex pulled in 41 billion in
revenue by themselves now this isn't an
exact science or anything but if we
divide each of their revenues by the
number of cards in circulation we'll see
that each mx customer is worth 366
dollars in revenue in contrast each visa
customer is only worth 21 dollars and
each mastercard customer is only worth
now this already paints a terrible
picture for visa and a mastercard but we
haven't even considered the elephant in
the room
here's the thing amex doesn't really
deal with debit cards so the vast
majority of their revenue truly comes
from just credit cards the same however
cannot be said about the other two visa
and mastercard are heavily involved in
the debit card game
visa has a total of 2.4 billion debit
cards in circulation and mastercard has
1.4 billion debit cards in circulation
so really each issued card is worth less
than 10 annual revenue for visa and
mastercard meaning that each mx customer
is 36 times as valuable
so here's how amex became the king of
credit cards and why high spenders far
prefer mx over visa and mastercard
taking a look back amex wasn't always
the high ticket closer that they are
today
in fact they weren't even a financial
business they were originally a shipping
business
it all started on march 18th 1850 when
three men named henry wells william
fargo and john butterfield decided to
join forces together these guys owned
three shipping businesses that they had
been running for a few years
the first company was called livingston
fargo and co and was founded in 1845 by
henry and william the second company was
called the wells and co and was founded
in 1846 by henry and finally the third
company was called butterfield and
wassen and was founded in 1849 by john
butterfield and james wassen at the time
railroads were a rather new invention
and the demand for sending shipments was
growing rapidly instead of competing
against each other and seeing who came
out on top though the trio decided to
combine their efforts and form a small
monopoly within new york called american
express the company mainly focused on
shipping goods between new york city and
buffalo but they also had some
destinations throughout the midwest as
well this proved to be an extremely
profitable regional business but neither
henry nor william were satisfied with
the justice market you see it these two
wanted to build a national business so
they wanted to expand to california and
capitalize on the gold rush however the
other board members would not approve
this expansion effort henry and william
weren't willing to give up this
opportunity though so they would start a
new express and financial services
business in california in 1852
i think it's safe to say that amex
messed up pretty big here given that the
new business was wells fargo nonetheless
things were going well for amex as well
they were expanding into the money order
business and their monopoly was still
intact up until 1866 when they saw their
first major competitor called the
merchants union express company amex and
merchants union fought fiercely for
market share over the next two years but
in 1868 they decided to simply join
forces and create american merchants
union express company honestly that's
quite a long and cumbersome name but
fortunately they would shrink the name
back to american express in 1873.
they had successfully avoided a
long-term clash with merchants union but
this fiasco made them realize the
importance of diversification and with
that mx would start to explore new paths
throughout the next few decades
amex started off by thinking of new ways
they could build customer loyalty and
provide more value many of mx's
customers were small local businesses
that were using amex to source their
goods
these local businesses didn't have the
resources to constantly travel to their
suppliers and negotiate better prices
but amex already had agents all over the
place so in 1878 mx started negotiating
with suppliers on behalf of their
clients and this has turned into one of
the trademarks of amex today
of course they're no longer negotiating
purchase orders instead they're
negotiating for high demand items and
experiences
no one knows exactly how amex pulls it
off but if you're a platinum cardholder
or better yet a centurion card holder
amex can get you anything you want
whether that be front row seats to a
lakers game or an invitation to justin
bieber's wedding
anyway going back to the 1870s this new
negotiation service was a massive hit
with customers and amex would follow up
to success with the travelers check in
if you're not familiar with what a
traveler check is it's basically just a
safer way to carry money with you while
you're traveling
instead of carrying cash you carry a
traveler check and redeem it for money
when you arrive at your destination
this was particularly appealing to
international travelers who regularly
traveled to europe this transformed amex
into an international business and they
would open offices in england germany
and paris soon after world war one
rolled around and the mx would score a
deal with the british government amex
was contracted to deliver letters money
and relief packages to british prisoners
throughout the war and by the end of the
war mx was delivering 150 tons of
parcels every single day to just
prisoners it looked like things couldn't
get any better but then the american
government would screw over amex
throughout the winter of 1917 the us
would experience a massive coil shortage
which meant that it became extremely
expensive to ship items across the u.s
this wasn't optimal for amex but given
that shipping rates had gone up across
the board amex didn't really have to
worry about losing customers to
competitors they did however have to
worry about the government on december
26 1917 president woodrow wilson ordered
the railroads to help in the war effort
by helping them move troops supplies and
a coal and all contracts between
railroad companies and express companies
were nullified while this was an
unfortunate turn of events amex couldn't
really complain given that the decision
was made for a much more important cause
wilson's next decision however was
definitely something worth complaining
about treasury secretary mcadoo proposed
the idea of consolidating all existing
express companies into a nationalized
company president wilson approved this
proposal and with that amex lost their
express business all express companies
were hurt but amex was hurt the most
given that they were the biggest company
they lost 10 000 offices 30 000
employees and their rights to 71 000
miles of railroad the new nationalized
company was called american railway
express agency and though the us would
return ownership to the private
companies in 1920 it would never be the
same amex had lost everything that was
unique to them they had given up a
highly respected personalized express
service and in return they basically got
a 40 stake in usps and no one likes usps
in 1929 the assets and operations of
american railway express would be
transferred to railway express agency
and that was basically the end of this
business the company declined for
decades until it finally filed for
bankruptcy in 1975.
i guess it was a good thing that mx sort
of diversified into travelers checks but
this didn't help much for the u.s the
great winter only lasted a couple of
months but for amex it would end up
lasting 41 years until they stumbled
upon credit cards
amex had considered the possibility of
launching a credit card as early as 1946
but it wasn't until the launch and
success of the dyno's club card that
amex decided to take the plunge at the
end of 1957 amex announced that they
were going to enter the credit card
business from the very beginning mx was
set on targeting the premium market and
capturing high spenders they charged an
annual fee of six dollars which was one
dollar more than the diners club's five
dollar fee amex figured that this would
make their cards seem more exclusive and
desirable and they were completely right
given the massive demand that followed
by the time the official launch happened
in october of 1958 mx had already issued
250 000 cards initially the cards were
printed on paper but in 1959 amex
introduced plastic cards with embossed
numbers similar to how everyone wants a
metal card today back in 1959 everyone
wanted amex's new plastic card amex
further built on this exclusive image
with a gold card in 1966 and a platinum
card in 1984. the platinum card was
invite only and amex only picked the
highest spenders with the best payment
histories aside from being hard to
qualify for the platinum card carried a
hefty annual fee of 250
which has since grown to 695
and to persuade people to pay these
hefty fees amex introduced their famous
membership awards program in 1991.
within just 10 years membership awards
became the world's largest card based
rewards program and the amex has held
this title ever since
aside from building an exclusive image
amongst customers mx was concurrently
building exclusive relationships with
merchants
they offered lower merchant fees to
restaurants and businesses if they
exclusively accepted american express
this worked pretty well between 1981 and
in 1991 but a group of merchants would
start to rebel against mx in 1991
instead of exclusively accepting amex
they started to exclusively accept the
visa and mastercard and with that amex
would back off with their exclusivity
deals but they would never give up their
exclusive image
even today exclusivity is the name of
the game when it comes to amex because
their business model is radically
different from the rest of the industry
most credit card companies make their
money on the high interest rates they
charge and given that 55 of americans
carry a credit card balance this is
quite profitable but this model would
never work for amex because they only
should card to customers with excellent
credit and the thing is people with
excellent credit don't carry balances
amex is well aware of this and this is
why many of their cards don't even allow
customers to carry a balance the amex
green card gold card platinum card and
centurion card are all charge cards
which means that you have to pay your
balance in full every month amex has
become more lenient over the past few
years and they have introduced
workarounds that allow you to sort of
carry a balance but this is by no means
their focus
in that case you might think that their
annual fees are their focus amex cards
often carry annual fees in the hundreds
of dollars and even thousands of dollars
but while this pose in a lot of revenue
it's not super lucrative you know
sourcing tickets to justin bieber's
wedding and giving customers accesses
into an airport lounges aren't exactly
cheap and given that their customers are
smart spenders most of them are not
gonna pay a five thousand dollar annual
fee unless they're confident they can
milk six thousand dollars worth of value
but then why does mx spend so many
resources on what seemed like a zero sum
or even negative some service well the
answer is that you are their partner and
they're willing to go to extreme lengths
to keep you happy and loyal
you see the key to mx's business is not
high interest rates or high annual fees
the key is the high fees they charge
merchants visa and the mastercard only
charge one and a quarter to two and a
half percent per transaction but
american express charges one and a half
to three and a half percent per
transaction this may not sound like much
but an extra 1 on every transaction adds
up super fast because of this most
merchants aren't a fan of amex but
they're forced to accept amex because
all the high spenders prefer to use amex
and this creates a super unique business
dynamic
visa and mastercard partner with
retailers to try to get you to spend as
much money as possible and pay as much
interest as possible
meanwhile mx partners with you to try to
get as many retailers accept their high
fees as possible and so far they've been
extremely successful at this given that
99 of us merchants who accept a credit
card also accept american express so how
about we keep up this streak and
continue supporting amex do you guys
have an mx card comment that down below
also drop a like if you're a fan of mx's
business model and of course consider
joining our discord community to suggest
future video ideas and consider
subscribing and see more questions
logically answered but until then i'm
hari and i'll see you guys on the next
one
you